In the Philippines, international aid begins flowing into the city of Tacloban...
...and other areas hit hard by Typhoon Haiyan.
In Saudi Arabia, thousands of foreign workers head to a deportation center in Riyadh...
...after the police crackdown on foreign workers without visas.
In Egypt, top Russian and Egyptian officials are holding talks in Cairo...
...on arms deals that could be worth as much as two billion dollars.
In Afghanistan, Shiites in Kabul beat themselves with chains...
...in memory of the martyrdom of a grandson of the prophet Mohammad.
And finally from Zambia, wildlife authorities test a lighting system...
...to curb human-wildlife contact.